MARTIN GORNER: Hello, and thank
you for watching "Google
Developers Live." This is a new
show called "root access
Berlin." We are recording at
the brand new studio at the
Factory in Berlin.
The startup community is
absolutely vibrant here.
The Factory is the
place to be.
It's a 16,000 square meter
campus that mixes young
startups, seasoned startups,
and creates a fantastic
innovation, to stimulate
innovation and new
technologies.
Please welcome Chad from
6Wunderkinder.
CHAD FOWLER: Thank you.
MARTIN GORNER: Chad, can
you introduce yourself?
CHAD FOWLER: Yeah,
I'm Chad Fowler.
I'm Chief Technology Officer at
6Wunderkinder, which means,
partially, that I'm
a programmer.
And probably mostly, I am the
seasoned guy in the young,
fresh startup, to
use your words.
MARTIN GORNER: All right.
So the product you do is
actually a very successful
cost manager.
Can you tell us more about it?
And I'll show on the screen
what it looks like?
CHAD FOWLER: Sure, OK.
So the product is called
Wunderlist.
And this is actually Wunderlist
2, which we
launched in December.
And I'm going to talk about
the implementation of it a
little bit later.
But it is a productivity tool
that we pride on being simple
and beautiful and just staying
out of your way.
So it's a place where you can
capture your own tasks for
personal or for work.
And you can share them with
others and even assign them to
people, and that
sort of thing.
MARTIN GORNER: So here, I
have actually done that.
I have created this work list.
And I have shared it
with you, Chad.
And you have a smartphone,
on which you can see it.
So let me add a work
item for you.
All right.
CHAD FOWLER: Easy.
MARTIN GORNER: Easy, yes.
Let's see how this works.
CHAD FOWLER: So this is our
native Android application.
You'll see that it
synchronized and
the task came through.
Something I forgot to mention
is we are a distributed
cross-platform product.
So we have a central
synchronization service.
But then, we have Windows,
iOS, Objective, Mac OS,
Android, and web clients.
MARTIN GORNER: So yes, this
looks extremely simple.
I add a task.
It pops up on my
other devices.
It pops up in the list of people
who share my list.
It's super simple.
CHAD FOWLER: Yeah.
That's what we want
you to think.
Or that's what we want
you to feel.
MARTIN GORNER: There must be 20
lines of code behind this.
CHAD FOWLER: Slightly
more than 20.
It ends up being a lot more
complicated than that, to
implement it and make
it be seen less.
Just then, you shared
one task with me.
I was not currently
working on it.
Neither of us was offline.
But it gets a lot harder when
you have multiple clients on
multiple platforms,
connected and/or
disconnected from the internet.
So effectively, the problem
that we have to solve is
similar to creating a
multi-master distributed
database system.
You may have multiple friends
and coworkers that you're
collaborating with that have
mobile phones and desktop
computers and connections via
the web, all of them making
updates all at the same time,
on the same lists and tasks
that you are.
So they're saving those
changes locally.
When they go offline, they could
be saving many, many
changes locally.
When they come back online,
they bombard
the server with changes.
And as you probably know, in
mobile development, every
connection you make is very
expensive, in terms of time
and potential battery life.
So the big problem that we had
to solve when we implemented
the synchronization layer is,
how can we allow clients to
batch up a bunch of requests and
effectively make them all
via one HTTP call and
get all of the
responses back all at once.
So we initially implemented
that in Ruby.
Our back end was written
in Ruby.
And we did it all in memory.
MARTIN GORNER: So this is
what it looks like.
CHAD FOWLER: Yes, exactly.
So the black box that says, go,
the first implementation
was done in Ruby.
It was all in memory.
And that worked when we had a
monolithic API that was all
written in one language.
But we're moving to a
heterogeneous distributed
service oriented type of
architecture, for many
reasons, including performance
and scalability.
So to do this, we decided
instead of having an in-memory
batch API layer, we would
do a batch API service.
So it takes the same format that
the original thing does.
But instead of just calling
things in memory, it makes
HTTP requests.
And this is a JSON document.
And it represents the request
and the response.
So a client would batch up
potentially multiple HTTP
operations.
You can see the methods are
listed, Get and Post,
and then the URIs.
And then the server does all
of the requests, in the
initial version, only serially,
and then packages up
the results, again in
a JSON document that
the clients can parse.
MARTIN GORNER: And so you chose
to recode your Ruby
server in Go.
CHAD FOWLER: Yes.
MARTIN GORNER: Why Go?
That seems like a no go, to add
a new language that nobody
knows about.
You have very little competency
in the world for
working with it.
CHAD FOWLER: Yeah, so
there are a few
different answers to that.
One of them is more
philosophical.
And that is, I think it's a
mistake for teams to be afraid
of new languages and
new technologies.
I understand why teams can be.
Now, when it comes to Go, Go
is really easy to learn.
I learned enough to do this
service watching one talk at a
conference, from a
Google engineer.
So it's a really good at
doing concurrency.
It's really good at
doing networking.
And in order to actually
deploy Go--
a beautiful thing about it is,
although it has all these high
level language things that
you're used to from languages
that have virtual machines,
there are no external
dependencies.
So it's really, really
simple to deploy.
Whereas, if we were to go for
JVM stuff, then we'd have to
get a JVM stack running our
infrastructure, Erlang same thing.
MARTIN GORNER: So for you, the
ease of deployment, lack of
dependencies, was the key.
I understand that, for other
people, having a strongly
typed language is
also important.
Go is that.
The performance part is, I
think, very important for a
lot of people.
Go is compiled into a
native assembler.
So it's close to
C performance.
But the big difference from
C is that it has memory
management.
So it is a garbage-collected
language.
CHAD FOWLER: Yes, I think of it
as a modern C, what I would
wish C would be today,
is what Go is for me.
MARTIN GORNER: And Go has
built-in concurrency patterns,
which we'll dive into shortly,
because that is what allows
you to program this service
very simply.
CHAD FOWLER: Yes, exactly.
MARTIN GORNER: All right.
So now we want root access.
Let's show the code.
CHAD FOWLER: OK.
Let's start by looking again at
the JSON document that we
were looking at a minute ago.
And the reason that concurrency
is interesting
here is, as I said, this
document could have maybe 40,
50 requests in a single
batch request.
And another way to say it is,
if you have 10 requests that
you're doing, and each one takes
one second on the back
end, then it could either
take 10 seconds.
Or it could take one second,
just to oversimplify.
MARTIN GORNER: And here, it
will take one second.
CHAD FOWLER: Correct.
MARTIN GORNER: But before
we go there, you
need to do HTTP requests.
There are handy libraries
for doing that in Go.
So let's see what
they look like.
So this is an HTTP client.
You import the library.
And really, the only
thing there is to
it is Get and Post.
It doesn't get any simpler
than that.
CHAD FOWLER: And that's included
with Go, as part of
the standard library, which
is a lovely thing.
MARTIN GORNER: And here's how
you do an HTTP server.
It's the same library.
And first, you have to look
at the main function.
You declare a handler.
You associate it to a URL.
And then you launch the serving
service, Listen and Serve.
And the handler is, again,
pretty much what you expect
from an HTTP handler.
It has a response writer for
writing the response.
And it has access
to the request.
CHAD FOWLER: Yes.
And this is a multi-threaded
server that can
handle a lot of load.
Just this little bit of code
here, that's actually what a
production Go server
looks like.
MARTIN GORNER: OK.
So let's dive into the real
code here and talk about
concurrency.
So here is the first part
of your black box.
What does this do?
CHAD FOWLER: So this is actually
the code where, given
a request, one of those JSON
documents sent from a client,
off screen, we're calling
extract batch operations,
which all it does is parse
the JSON of this request.
So we're extracting that into
a collection of operations,
which is what we've assigned
to ops here.
And then, the interesting
thing and the part that
demonstrates how concurrency
works is the line in red,
where we see rc equals
make chan Response.
What we're doing here is we're
declaring a variable called
rc, which is an instantiated
channel in Go.
And channels are how, in Go, you
have multiple concurrent
threads-- or Go routines is
what they're called--
able to talk to each other and
send messages to each other in
a thread slash concurrent-safe
way.
MARTIN GORNER: So the core
is the Go routine.
And that is the Go statement
that you see here.
What does that do?
CHAD FOWLER: So basically what
that does is, we could have
called request without
the word go there.
This is a really neat
thing about it.
It's like you add go
to the beginning or
right before a call.
And it turns something that was
otherwise done serially in
the same thread into
running into a new
thread or a new thread.
The threads in Go are called Go
routines, because they're
not exactly threads.
They happen to run on operating
system threads natively.
But they're smarter than that.
They can multiplex across
operating systems threads, in
case one gets locked up,
that sort of thing.
So it's a really high-level
environment.
And you can see, with just that
Go statement, you take
that was serial before,
and you turn it
into parallel code.
MARTIN GORNER: And actually, the
Go runtime can also decide
to run a Go routine as its
thread or to batch them up
inside one thread.
So you can have many more Go
routines than you would have
been able to have threads,
in any operating system.
CHAD FOWLER: Yeah,
it's a really
nice high-level construct.
So what we're doing here is,
we're calling the Request
function, which is something
that we built, which just
simply goes off and makes the
HTTP request that we've asked
for in that batch JSON.
And then we pass in
it this channel.
So that's how the new Go routine
is going to be able to
communicate back to the calling
code and give it the
response from the
batch request.
MARTIN GORNER: So let's see
how these calls come back.
What does this do?
This looks a little
bit unusual.
There is an infinite loop
on a Select statement,
on a channel response.
CHAD FOWLER: Yeah, it's very
similar to the Select call in
C. Although, what we're doing
here is, we're asking Go to
watch for I/O on channels.
So we say, Select, which tells
us it to watch and block for
I/O. And then we say, if we get
a response from this RC
thing, which is the channel we
made earlier, then we can
process it.
And the syntax that we have
highlighted here, where it
says less than dash rc--
that is basically saying,
we're taking
something out of RC.
It's a kind of a clever
visual syntax.
MARTIN GORNER: So on the
previous screen, we have
launched our 10 requests,
asynchronously.
And here, we are listening on
the channel, if one of those
is returning a response.
CHAD FOWLER: Correct.
MARTIN GORNER: One of those
or many of those.
How are you going
to deploy it?
Is it physically one box?
CHAD FOWLER: A beautiful thing
about this service is, it's
this much code.
And it's like technically maybe
three times as much code
as we saw, for the
entire thing.
But not only is it a small
footprint for the developers.
It's a small footprint
for the server.
So the way we're deploying it
is, we're actually just
putting it on all the servers,
so wherever we have app
servers, which really simplifies
our deployment,
because it's not eating
up so many resources.
We can just say, it's a part of
our standard server build.
And it's just always running.
It just goes extremely quick.
MARTIN GORNER: Thank you very
much for being with us on
"root access Berlin." And we
hope to see you soon, with
other startups, other
interesting technical
problems, and other--
I hope-- interesting technical
solutions.
Thank you, good-bye.
Thank you, Chad.
CHAD FOWLER: Thanks.